When you see like,
um,
like some of their,
uh,
like free bird,
that free bird solo that gets taught,
which is one of the greatest solos in the history of all music.
There's some specific reasons for this.
Okay.
One of the more specific reasons is you had to built,
it has a beginning,
a middle,
a crescendo and end their specific names to this.
Okay.
Um,
when we moved to more channels in recording,
when know Leonard Skinner,
he recorded all their early stuff has eight track and then you had to double up
or early Van Halen.
Same thing.
You had to compile your tracks or whatever.
I'm,
you had to really walk in with your solo written okay.
And play and you would work it until it really had a thing in crescendos.
Yeah.
Okay.
Once there were many tracks,
guys would come in and just wing it and go,
okay,
let's try one.
[inaudible]
okay,
great.
That's fine.
Let's do it again.
Track too.
And they just make it up as they go.
Okay.
And then when it's time to mix,
they'll put a little of track two and a little subtract six and start moving
those channels in a way that you would never think to play the guitar.
For example,
ed started doing that on a couple of tracks,
right?
Original Solos running with the devil.
Did it,
did it,
did it in.
Okay.
These are thematic solos.
Most Beatles Solos,
the matic you follow and listen to the solo in ain't talking [inaudible] these
are thematic solos.
When it started going,
whether they like this,
he'd record six different versions of the souls.
Okay.
And then just started move the channel like here,
turn this one on,
turn this one off,
turn this 100 and then he'd have to go learn the solo.
Wow.
So he will see his hand move from down here to up here and down there.
It became a gymnastic effort,
more elbow and shoulder to get his hand from the far end of the fret board all
the way up to the pickup and back to duplicate that,
uh,
Wabisabi.
Wow approach to making solos.
So it was a very oblique or unique kind of way of creating a solo.
It was utilizing the digital,
digital future,
multi tracking and improvising and fall as opposed to,
I'm going to sit down and I'm going to just,
I'm going to create something like a book.
Here's the beginning,
here's the scene here.
The character's,
here's the conflict.
Instead,
it's,
let's just mix that all up together in interesting ways.